Mother's Day is approaching and the
channel wants to pay homage to those women
who work hard to support
their families, each one with their own style, each
one in a different way, but in the end with
the heart of a mother who gives
everything for her  children, come with me to learn
the story of eric avilés
below my name is erika avilés I
was the owner and a businesswoman of my
own agency erika avilés consulting
for me it is a great pride and to have the
opportunity and the privilege of being a mother
because I can teach  and educate my
daughters about what it means to work hard to
have my own company and also to be able to
spend time and be at home with them and
enjoy both roles when they get
up is to have breakfast and all of them
are in iker's right now
because they are  girls still get
their lunch ready
try to do a little bit of homework or
practice what they have to do and
want to go with my husband he
typically takes them in the mornings and
then I  I get ready and I start my day here
at the office
with my meetings called depending on if
I have any tips and at the end of the day I
am the one who usually goes for them
we come home running because they
come hungry to make dinner to try
to live with living a  play
outside a little bit take them to the park walk a
little so that I can
also enjoy the time
with them challenges
is to maintain the balance between the two
positions for me it is important to have
those limits between what hours
I will work for my clients my
projects  It's three hours of work between
these dinner hours, even if it's them, I
don't have as much time with them in the
morning, in the afternoon, to
live with them and later, when
they fall asleep, I try to live with
my husband, too, because that's what I
'm still learning.  how to be a
mother
be a wife give myself time to
not feel guilty no I have felt
that I should work I should leave
my  The agency should be full time, not
with them and it helps me a lot to have that
check every month with my therapy to
say this is what I'm feeling and
process those peelings of those
feelings that I'm experiencing and then I no
longer feel better, that's why I don't  work
so hard to be able to give your
family and your children these opportunities. I
give thanks every day, I
live a lot, that's why I write three things
for which I am thankful today, not because
my parents made that sacrifice so
that I can have my own business that
my  daughters can have an education I am
always
not for moms who may be
suffering something is to see where something
that you can find positive about your
situation that my daughters see half they
see me working here sometimes at
night on weekends but  my
husband reminds me they are seeing
a mother a woman working and it will not
be anything out of the ordinary when they
grow up and see my mother work because I do not
report for  They swim in Spanish
Natalia Lancellotti